[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory Tom
marelo Riddle was born at wool's
orphanage on New Year's Eve 1926 to
marpi gaun a pure blood witch and the
daughter of marola gaun tragically
marpie died shortly after riddle was
born the result of a broken heart
abandoned by the man that she loved
often suffering complications from
childbirth paired with starvation and or
hypothermia marpie no longer had any
desire to live and made no attempts to
utilize magic to save her own life
marpie refused to raise her wand even to
save her own life she wouldn't even stay
alive for her son Dumbledore raised his
eyebrows could you possibly be feeling
sorry for Lord Voldemort no said Harry
quickly but she had a choice didn't she
not like my mother your mother had a
choice too said dumble gently yes marip
riddle chose death in spite of a son who
needed her but do not judge her too
harshly Harry she was greatly weakened
by long suffering and she never had your
mother's courage Mar's death meant that
she was never there for Tom and because
of this he grew up without any concept
or notion of love something that many
considered to be a lasting effect of the
love potion that marpie had used on
Tom's Father Tom Riddle senior and it's
Voldemort's inability to feel love that
is widely perceived to have catalyzed
his path of villain many believe that
thanks to his mother and father
Voldemort was in a way destined for evil
I've seen it posted and stated just
about everywhere that Voldemort is
fundamentally incapable of feeling love
but in my opinion this is one of the
most misunderstood aspects of the story
the most common interpretation is that
because he was born under a love potion
there exists no possibility for him to
feel love or similar emotions
but this has actually been cleared up by
JK Rowling in an interview how much does
the fact that Voldemort was conceived
under a love potion have to do with his
inability to understand love is it more
symbolic it was a symbolic way of
showing that he came from a Loveless
Union but of course everything would
have changed if marpie had survived and
raised him herself and loved him in just
a few sentences here JK rling opens up
the possibility of Voldemort loving
something someone she said it herself if
marpi had survived and been there to
raise him then there's a very good
chance that he could have loved this
means that he was never quite as
emotionally incapable as other Cannon
suggests so my question is if the
transformation of Tom Riddle into vort
could have been avoided by some love and
care then what on Earth happened to him
at the orphanage I suppose it's possible
that he simply needed the love and care
of his mother but weren't the caregivers
at the orphanage good to Tom or was it
actually Tom's upbringing that was
directly responsible for creating the
monster that tore apart the Wizarding
World in the heart of bustling London
tucked away in a forgotten Corner stood
wool's orphanage a desolate Refuge where
Tom Riddle spent the first 11 and a half
years of his life the orphanage itself
was described as a grim Square building
surrounded by high railings with stone
stairs in a bare Courtyard within the
orphanage Tom Riddle had a single room
that contained an iron bed dead an old
wardrobe and a hard wooden chair the
room's only decoration came from seven
stones sitting on a window sill and a
photo of a cliff on the wall inside the
air hung heavy with a sense of Despair
as if the walls themselves wept silently
for the Unfortunate Souls that called
this place home faded threadbear
curtains grimaced in the feeble light
that filtered through smudged Windows
casting a palid and sorrowful Hue over
the sparse and worn out Furnishings the
creaking floorboards echoed with muffled
size of longing and each room held rows
of narrow discomforting beds decorated
only by Thin blankets that hardly
provided respite from the chill that
seeped through the cracked walls the
truth is Tom Riddle couldn't have been
in an orphanage during a worse time
period the orphanage system in the UK
only really began to take off in the
19th century which meant that it was
still very much in its infancy
furthermore 1926 the year Voldemort was
born was the very same year that the
child adoption Act was passed in the UK
which finally made child adoption legal
during Tom Riddle's time there the
circumstances were nothing short of
terrible the aftermath of the first
world war had left a surplus of War
orphans combined with programs aiming to
remove Street children from the Grim
city streets this sudden influx of
children easily overwhelmed the existing
system resulting in overcrowded facil
facilities and a Severe lack of
resources many orphanages were unable to
cope with the overwhelming demand and
were forced to shut down or merge with
others the dire conditions led to scarce
Provisions with it not being uncommon
for multiple children to share a bed or
sleep on the floor shoes were considered
a luxury and most orphans were lucky to
have only one or two sets of clothes one
for winter and one for summer lack of
nutritious food was a constant struggle
and orphans often subsisted on the same
meager and watered down soup or porridge
for weeks on end overworked caretakers
who were stretched thin and in many
cases were neglectful or even abusive
added to the challenging atmosphere to
make matters worse during this time many
children as young as 12 were forced into
labor working grueling hours in docks
and factories with hygiene conditions
deteriorating diseases like diptheria
chera and measles flourished leaving
malnourished children with weakened IM
immune systems vulnerable to these
illnesses and as if the conditions were
not already dire enough in 1931 the
Great Depression struck the United
Kingdom coinciding with Tom being just 5
years old orphanages lost a significant
portion of their funding exacerbating
the scarcity of food and resources the
reality of death surrounded the young
children with illness and disease
claiming the lives of those all around
them something that I feel further
ingrained Tom's fear and obsession with
mortality in this grim and despairing
environment Tom Riddle was forced to
endure navigating a world where Hope was
a scarce commodity and the Spectre of
death loomed ever closer Tom experienced
firsthand the fragility of Life the
constant presence of death whether
through diseases malnourishment or the
loss of peers reinforced his awareness
of mortality from an early age this
heightened awareness of death and the
transience of life left a lasting impact
on Tom's psyche
by 1938 when Dumbledore first visited
Tom things had improved a little just 2
years prior the departmental committee
on adoption agencies had been appointed
and Dumbledore's description of the
orphanage as shabby but spotlessly clean
is a good indicator that things were
moving in the right direction but that
doesn't take anything away from the fact
that for the majority of his time at the
orphanage Tom Riddle lived in absolute
squala this brings me to my first point
the environment of Bull's orphanage
combined with the harsh economic and
social realities that surrounded Tom
Riddle left little room for the growth
and development of positive emotional
traits such as love and compassion the
constant struggle for resources lack of
Direction and early exposure to hardship
and loss made it impossible for Tom to
find the emotional nourishment needed
for healthy growth and development
instead of love and compassion Tom
developed an overwhelming desire for
power control and recognition
conceived under a love potion left
behind by his mother and growing up in
this sort of environment meant that Tom
Riddle never really had much of a chance
after beginning his studies at Hogwarts
in 1938 Tom continually expressed a
strong desire to avoid returning to W's
orphanage for the Summers on one
occasion even making a special request
to the then Headmaster of Mundo dippit
to remain in school during the holidays
and how could we blame him after his
very first year at hogw Tom returned to
London during a time of heavy
preparation for war the city was in the
process of building air raid shelters
and readying anti-air guns and balloons
while the call for military service
began as summer neared its end Tom
discovered that not only he but also the
majority of London's child population
including his fellow orphans were being
evacuated to the countryside over
800,000 children have been relocated
from the city by early September on the
day Tom left for Hogwarts in September
Germany invaded Poland marking the
beginning of World War II the British
army mobilized and two days later the
United Kingdom officially declared war
on Germany and when he returned to
London at the end of his second year he
found the city in a state of panic
France had recently fallen and the
Battle of Britain had begun with German
and British fighter planes engaging in
aerial combat rationing had commenced
air warning drills became a normal part
of daily life and on August 9th the
Birmingham Blitz commenced which
although not directly affecting London
sent shock waves throughout the entire
United Kingdom if we fast forward to the
summer before his seventh year at
Hogwarts Tom would have bore witness to
the first V1 missiles to hit London
which claimed the lives of over 6,000
people in a 12-day period and though by
this time Tom had already heavily
descended Into Darkness the catastrophic
warming of London by the Germans would
have only further catalyzed Tom's jaded
perspective on the world and perhaps
served as motivation for some of his
more Twisted World philosophies such as
the idea that there is no good or evil
only Power and to those too weak to seek
it in an environment where the primary
goal is survival like the impoverished
and desperate conditions faced by Tom
moral and ethical considerations tend to
take a back seat the immediate Focus
becomes ensuring basic needs like food
and water are met often trumping any
concerns for the well-being of others in
situations like this power becomes a
critical Factor those who possess power
have control of the resources which
means they have access to more food and
essential items the individuals who lack
power or are deemed too weak are left to
suffer and potentially starve this is
likely a contributing factor in
Voldemort's growing obsession with
achieving power furthermore as the city
faced Relentless bombings and
destruction the constant threat of death
pervaded the atmosphere this only fur
further magnified the fragility and
impermanence of Life exacerbating Tom's
obsession with his own mortality the
destruction and loss all around him
intensified Tom's belief that life was
fleeting and fragile seeing the
consequences of war the suffering
inflicted upon innocent people and the
indiscriminate nature of death
strengthened his resolve to transcend
mortality desperate to assert control in
the face of such destruction he saw
power as a means to protect himself from
the horrors he witnessed believing that
if he gained enough control and
influence he could avoid the same fate
that so many others
suffered next I want to touch on
something directly tied to the
orphanages that have somehow managed to
avoid so far we've healthily established
the Social and economic struggles
associated with the time period but I
haven't even begun to touch on
intrapersonal Dynamics within the
orphanage we know that lack of love and
care contributed to Voldemort's Town
fall but I wonder how that happened is
it just that he wasn't nurtured or was
he actively mistreated the 1930s and 40s
witnessed the profound societal impact
of looming World War II which caused
immense distress and uncertainty for
many individuals and the caretakers at
Tom Riddle's orphanage were no exception
to this as key figures responsible for
the Children's Welfare they grappled
with the pressures and anxieties
associated with living through such
tumultuous times and during these
periods of great stress and adversity
individuals would often seek solace in
unhealthy coping mechanisms like alcohol
I think that the caretakers at the
orphanage burdened by the weight of
wartime stress may have turned to
alcohol as a method of emotional relief
and escapism Mrs Cole was the Muckle
matron of W's orphanage and do we see
evidence of her alcoholism when she is
questioned by Dumbledore Dumbledore did
not press her though Harry could tell
that he was interested she took yet
another gulp of gin and her Rosy Cheeks
grew Rosier still Billy stubs rabbit
well Tom said he didn't do it and I
don't see how he could have done but
even so it didn't hang itself from the
rafters did it I shouldn't think so no
said Dumbledore quietly but I'm jiggered
if I know how he got up there to do it
all I know is he and Billy had argued
the day before and then Mrs Cole took
another Swig of Jin slopping a little
over her chin this time and while
alcohol can provide temporary respite
from negative events it often
exacerbates volatile emotions and
impairs judgment for the caretakers Tom
rid's orphanage the consumption of
alcohol as the coping mechanism may have
led to heightened frustration and
aggression towards the children in their
care drunken interactions could easily
devolve into mistreatment as their
inability to manage stress and emotions
spilled over into their caregiving roles
furthermore in the 1920s abuse in
orphanages was not particularly uncommon
through strict disciplinary measures
orphans would be subjected to physical
punishment including beatings slapping
or other forms of of physical violence
and this abuse inflicted by harsh
authoritarian caretakers would often
result in physical injury or long-term
psychological harm in the case of
Voldemort it was the latter by the time
Dumbledore visited Tom at the orphanage
he was old enough and aware enough to
make bad things happen to people the
caretakers and the other children were
afraid of him but Tom had been at the
orphanage since he was an infant which
means that he may have been the target
of abuse prior to him even being old
enough to acknowledge it he only endured
it for as long as he remained out of
touch with his magical ability as an
adult Voldemort's ideology was founded
on the notion that Wizards were
inherently Superior to Muggles and they
ought to exercise their power over them
an ideology that was unquestionably
shaped by his difficult childhood
experiences growing up in a war torn
environment at an abusive orphanage
Voldemort didn't exactly see the good
side of Muggles and though he committed
an unforgivable number of atrocities
later in life I can't imagine how young
Tom Riddle could have ever really stood
a chance what do you think had you ever
considered Voldemort's upbringing to
this extent the war torn environment and
psychological hardships he had to endure
let me know down in the comment section
below also if you enjoy the content
please like the video and subscribe to
the channel until next time remember it
does not do to dwell on dreams and
forget to
live